I
I think I slipped on a pair of really
nice shoes and I'm rocking it really
nice I don't flirt I just say what I
want what do you want I don't think that
I've ever seen a character that fans
have immediately fell in love with so
quickly than with Luke well I mean I
think ultimately luke cage comes with
his own fan base and I can't take credit
for it jessica jones star Mike culture
staying humble about his role as fan
favorite Luke Cage man like you but
season one was just the tip of the
iceberg the luke cage sandal own series
hits netflix on September 30th what can
you tease for all those Luke Cage fans
out there you're definitely going to get
a chance to see the backstory a lot of
stuff you saw on jessica jones the
questions you had the ambiguity to
vagueness Luke has a lot of skeletons in
his closet he will unleash a lot of the
the information that people are dying to
get you while Mike is mum about whether
Jessica Jones will be in the spin-off
the two will share the screen in the
defenders the netflix and Marvel series
that teams the hell's kitchen heroes
with daredevil and iron fist how do you
think your girl Jessica's gonna fit in
with all those defender guys she's got
enough to hold her on I think it's gonna
be great to have the one girl I I don't
think I don't think any girl doesn't
like being the only girl room I think
she's gonna be just fine
you